there was a time where if you googled
shiba inu you'd mostly get educated on a
cute breed of japanese hunting dog
search that now and you'll also get
plenty of articles about what has become
the 11th biggest cryptocurrency by
market value in one of the quickest
rises ever seen
[Music]
high today
shiba inu or shib made its debut on
august 1 2020. it aspired to be an
ethereum based alternative to dogecoin
another cryptocurrency based on the same
dog and its subsequent memes
shibb's starting price was fractions of
a penny and was intended to be abundant
with a circulating supply of one
quadrillion by october 27 2021 shibb
really took off the coin gained 680 in
value during that month it has since
gone through the usual wild fluctuations
we've seen with other cryptocurrencies
but still remains way up from its
initial price last year
insider even reported of one 35 year old
uk man who put in an initial investment
of eight thousand dollars and came out
on the other side with one million
dollars quitting his job as a warehouse
manager
so yes shiba inu may have started as a
bit of a joke but the financial gains
can be very serious and we do have some
questions about where things will go
from here
first what factor does sheer enthusiasm
play when it comes to the performance of
an altcoin like ship
one thing you'll find out as you look
into shiba inu is the community
supporting it really loves it similar to
the meme stocks of wall street bets
there's plenty of daily discussion on
reddit and other social media platforms
about the token so the price jump is
largely driven by the community of
course they are
the force behind the fact that uh major
cryptocurrency exchanges including
coinbase now listed ship on on their
platforms i think the 35 billion market
cap should tell you something about how
strong this committee is first of all
um an india-based crypto exchange even
went down uh largely because of the
demand around around the token the value
of shiva inucoin actually like depends
on people power and
also um interestingly there is a dose of
fomo among like the shiva inu community
um among especially among those who
think that they missed out on the
dogecoin boom some experts characterize
supporters of shiba in the coin as fat
buyers but for now it looks like shiva
unicoin is still very popular another
wild card to consider is elon musk the
tesla and spacex founder has publicly
stated he holds bitcoin ethereum and
dogecoin and anytime he tweets about
anything doge both that and shiba inu
can see their prices fluctuate second
question
does offering altcoins at such a low
price increase the appeal of investing
in crypto to a broader audience
buying one full token of the more
established coins like bitcoin or
ethereum takes quite a bit of money so
many investors end up buying fractions
but part of the appeal with shib is
being able to buy large numbers of full
tokens for a low price per unit online
you do see investors cite the low price
as an influence to buy in and in the
weeks since ships rise other low priced
altcoins have seen their values go up
but looking at the big picture shiba inu
might not be as widely distributed as
the price would have you believe the
ownership of shibaino is heavily
concentrated on a small number of people
and when i went to check double check it
it turns out that top 10 wallets hold
more than 70 percent of shiva inu coin
so while um the ship community is very
strong um when you look at
who like the number of people who
actually hold the coin it's heavily
heavily concentrated on a small number
of people
finally does having an
anti-establishment vibe help increase
shibs appeal and value while shiba inu
is not gamestop there are overlaps in
the online dialogue and excitement
around its rise
and like gamestop you can see an
undercurrent of sticking it to the
financial establishment and cnbc
analysts who may not necessarily take
crypto as seriously
wouldn't it be amazing if we could stop
talking about bitcoin and start talking
about stock sometime
the white paper itself talks like a lot
about community decentralization freedom
revolution and it also states um tearing
down a long established paradigm of
formulaic success so yes i would say
definitely that there's a component of
like decentralization and trying to like
break away from like traditional method
of trading and one unique element for
shiba inu's situation is that it does
have a direct rival maybe saw dogecoin
back in the day as anti-establishment
after
the game stop craze and other meme
stocks uh
kind of cooled off and now with elon
musk supporting uh dogecoin uh you could
even say that dogecoin is now part of
the establishment and chiba inu is now
anti-anti-establishment
and with this kind of a price war that
they have with deutsche point
um
this competition i think
uh does add up to to the growth that we
are seeing it's still too early to tell
in the long term if shiba inu becomes a
relatively stable token or tanks like
the squid game coin but it's safe to say
it has defied all expectations and is
definitely one asset to watch as we head
into 2022
you